françoise hardy on va vous faire une
interview tous les garçons et filles de
mon âge
françoise est ce que comme tous les
garçons et les filles de votre âge vous
regarder des chiffres et des lettres
absolument est ce que comme tous les
garçons les filets votre âge vous
regrettez les années 60
je regrette les années à venir que je ne
vivrai pas avec vous aviez un truc
terrible jour j'y pense sans elle m'a
dit un truc un jour elle m'a dit genre
il nous reste puisqu'on a perdu
pratiquement le même âge tu te rends
compte qu'il nous reste peut-être que 20
noël ou vingt fois à voir fleurir les
lisent à chaque fois ça m'a fait flipper
j'y pense tous les jours je me dis 10 me
trompe lalaurie ça c'est pas mal
françoise hardy est ce que comme tous
les garçons et les filles de votre âge
d'être fan de jacques dutronc
j'ai pouvons je crois qu est ce qu il
doit bien y en a tant vécu
est ce que comme tous les garçons les
filles votre âge de les prendre votre
retraite sur la côte d'azur
mais c'est déjà faire est ce que comme
tous les garçons les filles de votre âge
vous portez des thermolactyl de damart
tous les hivers papa ce soir est ce que
comme tous les garçons et les filles de
votre âge vous raconter toujours les
mêmes histoires à table gens racontent
aucunement gpra votre location est ce
que comme tous les garçons la vie de
votre âge j'avais les jambes lourdes en
fin de journée comme tous les garçons et
filles de votre âge est ce que vous avez
arrêté de vous droguer non mais je vais
peut-être commencer bientôt
est ce que comme tous les garçons et les
filles de votre âge qu'on soit zardi
vous lisez la rubrique nécrologique
avant l'horoscope albert qui qui voyait
d'un très mauvais oeil mon intérêt pour
l'astrologie qu'ils aient j'ai mis mon
horoscope aujourd'hui était déjà très
très âgées il me dit on me conseille de
prendre conseil justement de gens plus
âgés nuit mais y en a plus est ce que
comme tous les garçons les filles de
votre âge et susceptibles quand on vous
parle de votre âge ça vous dérange pas
sur les 85 ans
mon saut d'arrivée les messieurs dans ce
livre que je vous recommande s'appelle
les rythmes du zodiaque et sérénité au
cherche midi
quant au disque s'appelle message
personnel et c'est chez vertige